please be seated everyone
well here we are again back in the
chamber i think we've been where have we
been
the chamber then it was ramsey sports
center
then it was
then it was my house
then it was
what seems like it seemed like at the
time and then it was the winter gardens
but now we're back here
so well done thanks everyone for coming
along this evening now good evening
members and office of council and
members of the present public i welcome
you to this meeting of the council
first of all the fire evacuation
procedures if the fire alarm is
activated please vacate the offices via
the stairs either through the security
doors to my right or opposite the lifts
in the foyer please do not use the lifts
please assemble in hawley square on the
green officers will assist you and
advise where it is deemed safe to return
to the chamber with respect to filming
of the meeting i advise that if filming
takes place anyone in attendance in the
public areas may have their image
captured
i urge anyone filming proceedings to
avoid filming members of the public
particularly if there are children
present
now does anyone intend to film the
meeting
and i don't see any indications
any filming or recording will not be
permitted for any item of business where
exempt or confidential information is
considered following exclusion or press
and public from the meeting which causes
academics since no one's going to film
and now restrictions on the use of
mobile phones would everyone present
please ensure that their mobile phones
are turned to silent and they are not
used to make up or receive phone calls
whilst in the meeting
and we attend that everyone well done
so right i move on to agenda item one
apologies for absence apologies have
been received from councillors day
councillor farence councillor pugh and
councillor bailey are there any other
apologies this evening
yes councillor piper
councillor linda potts she's very unwell
that's why she's not here
thank you
councillor stuart piper did you indicate
as well
no
cancer curry
counselor pat moore thank you very much
indeed any other apologies
and i don't see any thank you very much
indeed
agenda item 2 announcement i've not been
informed of any announcements so i'm not
going to make any
agenda item 3 declarations of interest
are there any declarations of interest
of course councillors do receive an
automatic exemption for this since it's
the budget this evening
there are no others i believe to be made
therefore
agenda item four
this is the treasury management strategy
statement minimum revenue provisional
policy statement and annual investment
strategy for 2022-2020
councillor david saunders it's your
moment
thank you very much chairman
this report is required in accordance
with the cipfa code of practice on
treasury management
it covers our capital spending and
financial plans and its treasury
strategy backed by prudential indicators
and limits
the report also presents for approval
the council's minimum revenue provision
policy
capital strategy investment strategy and
non-treasury investments report for the
next financial year
this report was considered by the
governance and audit committee on the
first of december 2021
and by cabinet on the 13th of january
2022.
members i move the recommendations
thank you very much council saunders do
you have a seconder
i have councillor ashby
thank you very much
uh do members agree
i agreed thank you very much indeed
i move on to agenda item
oh
gender item five
the hra budget for 2022-2023
i advise that in accordance with council
procedure rule 17.6 i will call for a
recorded vote on the motion or any
amendment and substantive motions i
therefore once again call upon
councillor david saunders
thank you again chairman
next year's hra budget is underpinned by
a 4.1 percent increase in rents
and i am advised that the majority of
this increase will be covered by
increased benefit or universal credit
payments to the tenants
this rent increase is needed to continue
to drive the hra to a balanced and
sustainable financial position and also
to finance our ambitious house building
program and health housing investment
plan
which includes substantial investment in
our tower blocks and continued funding
for our upgrading heating and thermal
efficiency towards tackling the
council's climate change objectives
it has been good to see the improved
performance in terms of the delivery of
the housing capital program from our new
in-house tenant and leaseholder
services team
over time the improved delivery of
planned maintenance will help to reduce
overall revenue maintenance costs and
these efficiencies can help to further
improve the sustainability of the hra
business plan for future years
i move the recommendations chairman
thank you very much councillor saunders
you have a secondary
councillor ashby
councillor whitehead you wish to speak
at this point
thank you very much chair
and thank you councillor saunders
and i have a couple of questions would
you like to stand perhaps
um i can stand spine wise i will
probably struggle i'm afraid
um but yes at your discretion
and i have a couple of questions if
that's okay
firstly in relation to 3.0.1
considering the recent news relating to
the rise in utilities and specifically
gas and electricity which stands to hit
all of our residents incredibly hard are
we expecting to be forced to revise our
expected direct expenditure
given the predictions for contract and
price inflation
secondly to reference 3.1.1
in 2016 when central government required
councils to cut rents by one percent
each year in order to reduce central
costs
the direct impact of this was to force
many councils including ourselves into
hra deficit and difficult financial
situations
due to lack of income maintenance and
investment in stock has been a financial
challenge as you noted
and thus increasing rents in line with
cpi plus one is something that is
necessary for the vast majority of
councils due to the pressure applied to
hra funds by central government
previously
many of our tenants potentially affected
by this increase as you noted will have
the increased cost of their rent covered
by benefits
however a proportion of our tenants will
be affected by this increase
under the labour administration we
sought to mitigate this by waiving the
cpi plus one increase for those on
affordable rent as this particular
demographic group were most likely to be
paying the increase directly
have cabinet made the same provision
within this year's budget
thank you
thank you councillor whitehead council
saunders are you in a position i'm sure
you are to answer some of that
in a word not completely um councillor
whitehead knows that i've been listening
um to uh on several occasions and
we've spent an awful lot of time
with the budget holders going through
what we can and what we can't do
what you see before you
is the best that we can achieve in order
to
go forward with this balanced budget
i will take up the points you raise
with the housing team and come back to
you if necessary but we are where we are
and you have the paper before you and
that's the paper we're considering thank
you
thank you councillor saunders
councillor everett
yes thank you chair um uh with due
respect to councillor saunders and we're
invited to approve a budget i think we
should know what's in it can the cabinet
member not tell us whether the cabinet
has made a provision to protect um
people on affordable rents from this
inflationary increase in the same way
that the labour administration did
thank you councillor everett it's quite
difficult i'm sure to answer on the hoof
but nevertheless councillor saunders
is there anything you'd like to add
i'd like to uh refer the question if i
can to
our fallen financial director chris
blundell if he has a word
we don't have bob porter here with us
this evening for me to talk to bob
porter
but it is my expectations and hope that
in fact we have done exactly that
if chris can help thank you very much
councillors that does seem reasonable uh
mr blundell would you like to reply
thank you chair uh you'll see from the
report that the increase in uh rent is
applied uniformly across the both
affordable affordable and social brands
so it's a
divergence from previous
approaches but uh i believe uh if i'm
not corrected the phrase was previously
to
social as a post affordable rants
thank you mr blundell uh
do i have any other
debate i don't think i do so therefore i
shall instruct the deputy monitoring
officer to conduct the recorded vote
thanks very much chair i shall read out
your names and if you would say whether
you are in favor
abstain sorry if you're in favor against
or you abstain
councillor alban
four
councillora
paul
councillor ashby for
councillor austin
councillor bambridge
councillor jill bayford
councillor robert bayford four
councillor boyd
four
councillor braidwood
or
councillor coleman cook
four
councillor crittenden
councillor curry
four
councillor dennis
councillor dexter
councillor duckworth
four
councillor everett four
of fellows
councillor ghana
councillor gregory
four
councillor hart
councillor hopkinson
councillor huxley
councillor keane
councillor cup
four
councillor lays
councillor paul moore
council oven
councillor parsons
councillor linda piper
councillor stuart piper
councillor ratigan
councillor roth
[Music]
councillor rogers
councillor rozeki four
councillor david saunders
councillor maeve saunders
councillor savage
four
councillor scoby
councillor scott
councillor shank
councillor wallin
councillor whitehead
four
councillor wing
councillor wright
and councillor yates
oh
that's unanimous chair
thank you very much indeed uh
you heard the result there
now moving on to agenda item six
the budget 22 to 23 and the medium turn
financially financial strategy 20 22 26
i advise that in accordance once again
with council procedure rule 17.6 i will
call for a recorded vote on the motion
or any amendments and substantive
motions i therefore come back to you
councillor saunders
thank you chairman
this report presents the budget for
2022-23 along with the capital program
as previously provided to both the
cabinet and the overview and scrutiny
panel
it is now well versed that we were
forecasting a significant budget gap but
with a planned and cautious cautious
approach combined with an efficient
savings plan we have been able to
balance our budget despite what may seem
like a lengthy and complicated process
the level of planning is critically
important
it's how we continue to deliver the
services that matter to the people and
protect and support our most vulnerable
residents
planning our finances in this way means
we are
on the right track
for balancing the budget in the
forthcoming years
our balanced budget position has been
supported in part by the very welcome
additional funding that has been
provided to us by government for next
year
however much of this funding is
temporary and therefore careful
consideration will be given to its use
allocating those these resources in the
most appropriate and prudent way will
help ensure this authority moves into
the medium term on the most sound
financial footing possible
this is the prudent and responsible
thing to do
for example we plan to use the extra
one-off new homes bonus winfield winfor
rather to pay off debt and hence putting
us on a solid financial footing as we
prepare for the reform of local
government funding and the uncertainty
that this brings
despite the additional funding we have
received it has been necessary to find
budget savings in order to balance next
year's budget
one of our priorities throughout the
budget setting process has been to
protect jobs as much as possible and as
such a key component
of our budget strategy has been to look
for savings from vacant posts
i'm therefore pleased to present savings
of a quarter of a million pounds has
been found from this review
in addition to this we have found almost
another four hundred thousand pounds
from further savings efficiencies and
income generation opportunities
finally the proposed increase in council
tax at five pounds per banned d
equivalent property represents an
increase of less than 10 pence a week
for each household within that band
chairman i move the recommendations
thank you very much indeed councillor
saunders it's not going to cost me too
much do i have a secondar councillor
ashby thank you very much indeed uh
councillor yates you'd like to speak
thank you chair
labour would like to thank the council's
finance team and council officers for
their work on this year's budget
once again we all sat discussing a
budget that is significantly less than
the council's budget in 2010
and it continues to make me angry that
local councils are expected to continue
to function in a high inflation post
code environment with so few financial
resources
looking back at labour's labour's year
years running the council we are proud
that the majority of our actions remain
untouched
from hiring additional environmental
operatives providing our kitchen food
club with rent free premises
introducing our first 24-hour winter
shelter bringing margate harbor arm back
in house
increasing council tax to 300 for
long-term empty properties and the
hiring of a climate change officer
and decreasing taxi licenses charges for
electric and hybrid taxis
when it comes to the environment even in
opposition we're not complacent and just
this week we have sent officers a link
to a british company who can provide tdc
with two free electric vehicle trucks on
a two-week trial with charges included
let's be honest the next year is going
to be incredibly difficult for our
residents
last year's universal credit cut has
left left them with less money in their
pockets
utility bills are expected to jump by 50
in april
rental prices around thanet are going up
interest rates are creeping up and the
pandemic has not been kind to those on
low incomes
labour's budget look to support three
items homelessness climate change and
our public lifts
we are happy that this administration
have agreed to our climate motion agreed
overusing scrutiny and the climate
officers can now access an additional
reserve monies to maximize climate
funding streams coming into planet and i
for one certainly hope that thanit will
become a green destination for thousands
of tourists coming here each year
we are however disappointed that the
conservatives did not agree to our
homelessness or public lift amendments
this new homes bonus money is a one-off
situation and we believe that rather
than paying off debt we can invest today
in assets that will improve the lives of
our residents
paying off debt does nothing to
alleviate our residents concerns
and by the by the conservatives own
admission they are likely to have to use
that next year
when they do decide to invest in
additional temporary housing
accommodation
no doubt no doubt when interest rates
are much higher therefore my labour
colleagues tonight will be bringing two
amendments to amend the budget
these have both been checked by the
relevant officers in the council
firstly bringing back working lists
broadcast and ramsgate
and buying new property
to build new temporary homelessness
provision when interest rates are low
i hope these two amendments
which i'll now hand out
will receive cross-party support the
same way they did overview and scrutiny
and i thank you for listening
thank you very much indeed councillor
yates so i have council auburn
thank you chair um
first first of all chair i'd i'd like to
thank council saunders and the uh
our financial team for the hard work
that they put in to get a balanced
budget it is it's not an easy thing
to carry out
however
um i do wish to make an amendment
and uh the amendment to
the budget i wish to make is in relation
to
uh the new homes bonus
being spent or part of it being spent uh
on the refurbishment of both the
east cliff left in ramsgate and the
viking bay lifting broad stairs
now i know it's difficult for uh my
conservative colleagues to uh decide
to maybe go along with the labor
amendment
um but the amendment
i'm putting forward is for our residents
and for our visitors
we all know how much our
residents were up in arms
last summer when the lifts weren't
working
and we had some very vocal speakers
at our council meeting at the sports
centre
especially uh i think we need to look at
how our disabled residents
etc
can access our beaches
um
so what i'd like to to do chairman is to
uh
propose the the following amendment
uh which i shall now read out
the conservative budget proposed to use
549 000 to pay off debt the labor group
proposes to amend the budget allocation
instead we propose to allocate up to 230
000 pound of which councilor saunders
was kind enough to advise that would be
the cost for both repairs of both lifts
at the last cabinet meeting
uh
for the capital works required for the
rams ramsgate eastcliff and viking bay
coastal lifts to ensure they are in full
working order for the foreseeable future
and i move that amendment chair thank
you
thank you council auburn do you have a
seconder
deserve the right to speak later fair
enough thank you very much indeed for
that
do i have counselor piper did you wish
to come at this point
thank you uh mr chairman uh call call me
an old
pedentist if you like but um can i just
pick up on something please that council
yates said uh he talked about
cross-party support and approval at
overview and scrutiny for labour's
proposals can i just make it absolutely
clear that that is not what happened to
overview and scrutiny during the course
of discussing the proposed
amendments
councillor saunders was very kind enough
to suggest
ahead of any votes taken
that the cabinet would be happy to look
at all three proposals
so we carried out a perfunctory if you
like vote to thank him for his kindness
and agreed to pass it on to him largely
because as chair of that meeting i
thought it would be rather foolish to
turn down such a kind invitation so the
recommendation was sent back to cabinet
but largely because cadman offered to
receive it and scrutinize it and look at
it themselves there was no approval from
overview and scrutiny for those
proposals thank you mr chairman
thank you councillor for our councillor
piper for that clarification
and i presume that's something that the
members of that committee would be aware
of but it's being explained to all of us
here in council
uh any other speakers at this point
cancer
roth thank you chair um i
would like to join my colleague to thank
financial team during and all council
workers during this pandemic they work
all really hard and we should all
appreciate this and i take this
opportunity to thank all of them and i
urge all
members in this
chamber to
support the labour's amendment
especially their lift in ramsgate and
prostates and as you know we all know in
his 60s 70s than it was their holiday
place but no longer only holiday place
is a place for retired people and
families this lived every year a break
and i spent loads of time with the
offices and residents to find out why
this lived every year not been fixed and
i think it's a reasonable thing to we
put money in a site to be ready for it
this lift this was old second hand when
they bought it every year is getting
breaking and they have to send email to
germany to get a part for it it takes
two months by then summer will finish if
we not fix the have money ready for it
it never be ready to be fixed and people
cannot use it we denying disabled people
and families to get to these beaches and
we if we want to encourage people to get
to there we need to have a money ready
there to help the when is there not to
wait until the broken then we scratch
around and see if we can some money and
find the money then to fix it and you
need to think about the people also live
in thailand not just about oh let's
repay the debt first then we go to think
about it let's get away from stay away
from the culture of blaming on each
other's and stand uh
previous
administration or next one we need to
have money ready for these kind of
things when this happened emergency
housing
all we had all the time oh people come
to here they take our houses they do
this they do that and what about the
people live in here boring in this
country when they become homeless they
need
to uh place we need to have money for
our own people as well thank you
friends and council rule you did stray a
bit there but nevertheless uh with know
how that ah yes i think i got counselor
austin yes councillor austin
thank you chair um i'd like to uh
indicate support for this amendment um
on the basis of what uh uh previous
councils have said it supports people
who are disabled it supports young
families it supports older residents we
have an awful lot of those where where
my ward is in ramsgate um
i'll struggle to get my own husband down
into town and back uh without the lift
this summer i think um it really is very
very well used the east cliff lift and i
know that the same is true of the viking
bay lift it seems to me to be a sensible
investment to go for for this now
thank you
thank you council austin councillor
whitehead
thank you chair
um i'd like to speak very briefly for
once in relation to the overview and
scrutiny statement from councillor piper
it is true to say that councillor
saunders did
very kindly say that he would take
suggestions forwards to discuss at
cabinet and i thank him for that
but it is also equally true to say that
it did have cross-party support overview
and scrutiny
thank you councillor whitehead murmurers
of
uh councillor ashby
thank you chair um
on the subject of the lifts
um
we did consider obviously the proposal
regarding the lifts as we did the social
housing and i believe we cleared up the
um the other item that councillor yates
brought up regarding the reserves
it is felt obviously this is an
important um
asset
for the council and it's something that
i have been looking at very closely
so with regard to the broad stairs lift
i can
confirm that that we have had um
extensive conversations with the
broadstairs town council
it's an ongoing conversation and the
actual finalized um
[Music]
if you like end product needs to be um
ironed out um but it is felt much um
a more sensible way forward for the town
councils to take on this asset that way
they are in control of the situation it
can be a long-term
solution a sustainable solution
if that if the town councils take this
on now
in respect of the broad stairs
um lift
i and you might remember back um
after the spill for the southern water
when i wrote to southern water
um they did
well say kindly it's probably probably
the wrong word but they did agree to
donate a hundred thousand pounds
to um the
to be used as a discretion of the leader
to be used as a
a benefit to the community
so what um i've been working on is to
take half of that money for the
broadstairs lift
to
work a structure out with the
broadstairs town council so that we can
actually
take it forward and on a much more
sustainable and a forward plan it's no
good us just keep putting money against
these lifts and then two years later we
keep revisiting it
there is a way that these lifts probably
could end up
if you like paying for themselves
um with a little bit of imagination
but um that that is ongoing and um i did
speak with two ramsgate town councillors
um i believe it was september or october
and did suggest that i would do the same
or try and get the same sort of
arrangements together for ramsgate town
council and i i did leave it with those
councillors but i hadn't heard it i
haven't heard anything back but it is my
intention to
revisit that with ramsgate town council
so
basically um i'm offering to
divide the money equally between
broadstairs and ramsgate
to um for them to take the lift on under
a structure that we could sustain and
bring it forward so there is plans for
that and and i think it is much
um
it's a much better solution to do it
outside of the budget because the budget
is we are responsible for all of the
residents of the whole of planet and the
lifts don't necessarily benefit all of
the residents of all of thanet so
that is why i feel that is much better
if we find a separate solution uh around
that and and um
again point out that the hundred
thousand is to be equally divided
between broadstairs and ramsgate to find
a long-term sustainable solution for the
lifts of both those towns thank you
thank you very much indeed councillor
ashby uh that does seem to sort of uh
support concerns uh councillor everett
you did uh reserve the right yeah i'm
surprised you think it supports concerns
because i thought it was a load of
waffle
and i think the residents out in the
community who brought a petition to this
council and came and argued passionately
for the lifts to be opened will have
regarded it as a load of waffle and it
was very notable of course that
councillor ashby says she's entered into
discussions with brawlstairs town
council i'm sure she has because the
people of ramsgate will have no
confidence whatsoever in this
administration opening the left in
ramsgate
one of the facts that came out of the uh
the information provided to us by
officers about the lifts is that the
rams gate lift is considerably cheaper
to fix than the broad stairs lift not
something that we'd ever have thought or
ever have considered 87 thousand pounds
to fix the rams gate lift at one hundred
and thirteen thousand to fix the broad
stairs left councilor asked me said she
wants to do it outside of the budget i
think it needs to go into the budget he
needs to go into the capital program and
that's what this labour amendment will
do tonight
now the subject of paying down debt the
reality is that the conservative group
was suddenly presented with 549 000 that
they and the finance officers didn't
expect it arrived shortly before
christmas or news of it they didn't know
what to do with it so they invented this
fantastic idea that we're going to put
it in a reserve and at some point in the
future we're going to use it to pay down
debt as we've explored at the scrutiny
meeting and as we explore that cabinet
that is not a sensible way of managing
this situation the people of thanet the
people of ramsgate and broadstairs want
to see those lifts open members tonight
can vote for provision in the capital
budget they can vote to open the
broadstairs left and they can vote to
open the realms gate left or they can
vote not to do so and if they vote not
to do so all their residents will know
exactly what they did
i urge the council to support this
amendment
thank you very much councillor everett
council saunders would you like to wind
up
i would indeed and members will know
that i can't have all the chairs does
the portfolio holder get to wind up on
an amendment yes
thank you
he does i'm reliably assured council
everett
countered i wasn't going to wind up i
was i was i was just i was just getting
ready for my waxing lyrically with
regards to the passion that i have for
the viking bay lift
and members will know that i was
involved in the group which lobbied for
that lift back in the late 1990s and
you're absolutely right it's
disappointing that we've got a situation
we have at the moment
the figures that you had
were for the repairs
uh for the lift and refurbishments of
the lifts
of course there are additional costs
that you need to take into account for
the next financial year
that will get the lifts going absolutely
right we could have done that
you've then got to start thinking about
the administration who's going to open
the lifts who's going to close the lifts
who's going to clean the lifts and who's
going to be responsible for the
maintenance of those lifts because we
know that
they do suffer
i would say marge minor
issues as the year goes on
the other thing is that despite the fact
that we lobbied hard for the lift in
viking bay um and it was provided for
the year 2000s i now find that the
regulations
that have been brought in since 2000
mean that that lift is not fully
compliant
compliant with the current
disabled regulations i haven't looked
into that too deeply but it was looking
at the overall strategy for the future
and the future of those lifts so it was
the peripheral costs
that
moved us to
continuing with the strategy that
councillor ashby has outlined and
we may well look at it sympathetically
once we know exactly what the costings
are within that strategy unfortunately
councillor everett many on the cabinet
of the moment are graduates of the
margaret thatcher school of economics
and we do believe
can't have what you can't afford and we
don't believe we can afford all of the
costs at this point in time that are
associated with those two lifts and like
you i was surprised that the ramsgate
lift costings were lower than the broad
stairs viking bay costings
that's all i wanted to say on on that
subject thank you chairman
thank you very much indeed councillor
saunders and
and for the clarification for the
finances for the lift now i shall read
out the uh amendment as presented
the conservative budget proposes to use
the 549 000 to pay off debt the labor
group proposes to mend this budget
accordingly
instead we propose to allocate up to 230
000 from the new homes bonus allocation
to the capital works required to the
ramsgate east cliff and viking bay
coastal lifts to ensure they are full
working order for the foreseeable future
i shall then move over to the um
officer in order for the recorded vote
thank you very much
thanks very much chair so uh you're
voting on the amendment for against or
abstain
councillor alvin
four
councillora port
councillor ashby against
councillor austin
councillor bambridge
councillor jill bayford
councillor robert bayford
councillor boyd
councillor braidwood
councillor coleman cook
councillor christendon
councillor curry
for
councillor dennis
councillor dexter
councillor duckworth
for
councillor everett
council of fellows
councillor ghana
councillor gregory
councillor hart
councillor hopkinson
councillor huxley
councillor keane
counselor lays
councillor paul moore
councillor ovindon
councillor parsons
councillor linda piper
councillor stuart piper
councillor ratigan
councillor roth
councillor rogers
councillor rozeki
councillor david saunders
councillor maeve saunders
councillor savage against
councillor shrub
councillor smith
councillor tomlington
councillor towning
councillor wallin
councillor whitehead
councillor wing
councillor wright
and councillor yates
that's
30 against and 19 4.
thank you very much indeed that has that
the amendment has therefore fallen and i
take us back to the main agenda item
do i have
any speakers counselor
counselor bayford yes
well i shall yes councillor bayford i
think we'd like to indulge yeah
i'm probably wrong but um councillor
yates said that these amendments have
been checked and they're valid um but if
you look at this amendment it actually
says that the money that's being
proposed here is to part fund a
provision
of accommodation which presupposes that
the other bit of it somewhere in the
budget which it isn't so i don't see how
this can be a legitimate genuine
amendment
well i i think bearing in mind that uh
councilman davis broken councillor yates
you can come back to give us an answer
um unfortunately we live in a world
where that kind of money probably won't
buy you a property so the part funding
is
because most properties that are housing
well all properties the housing company
housing department will look to buy
going to be put are going to be more
than 500 000 pounds so that's why it's
the word part funding has been chosen by
our acting section 151 officer
yes thank you very much for that council
councillor whitehead councillor
whitehead um that's where on that can i
move them
councillor whitehead are you going to
read your amendment
can you turn your microphone i can't
hear what you're saying um is it
possible to reset please as i haven't
started yet and i speak a lot
oh i think we can indulge you there
councillor whitehead yes do
i'm proposing the following amendment
the conservative budget proposes to use
the 549 000 new homes bonus to pay off
debt the labor group proposes to amend
this budget allocation we propose to set
aside the remainder of the new homes
bonus to fund the provision of
additional in-house temporary
accommodation
i said in my first address to overview
and scrutiny that this is not a
political issue or a decision because it
isn't
politics at its very best is comprised
of individuals who want the best for
their society that sometimes disagree on
how to do it
so we debate and we discuss and if you
are certain that you are doing the right
thing you keep going
and i have never been more certain on
anything and i've also never been more
sure that everyone in the room
understands and sees the merit in this
amendment and i've never been more
terrified on behalf of residents that a
form of oppositional politics that i do
not ascribe to do not practice and do
not support could derail something that
our community needs more than anything
we currently have 160 households in
temporary accommodation 82 of those
households are placed out of area
evictions are increasing month on month
and margate tops the whole of the
country for property price inflation
over the last decade the lowest private
rents for three bed properties in
margate would now cost over 80 percent
of the income of our poorest residents
we are not approaching a crisis we are
already in one
it has been argued that using the new
homes bonus to hold back and pay down
debt is the fiscally responsible thing
to do
but as a council we do not routinely
hold debts on over 20 interest but what
is being proposed within this budget
will equate to that level at least
property values in margate alone rose by
14.4 last year they are predicted to
rise again to that level over the coming
year
cabinet acknowledge that we need to
expand our provision they simply don't
want to do it now and for reasons i find
more political than practical
the argument this is about being
fiscally responsible or prudent simply
does not hold water
if we allocate all of the new homes
bonus to acquiring in-house temporary
accommodation delaying purchases by one
year increases the cost of purchase by
an estimated 15 according to predictions
which means that delaying the purchase
of property now costs us an additional
82
350 pounds to buy equivalent property in
a year's time
there is no debt that we could pay down
now that is accruing interest at that
level
the argument is not sound and is the
opposite of fiscal responsibility
this is my last chance to make it clear
what a difference you can potentially
make tonight
families safe and not forced away for
every year from this point onwards
education not disrupted jobs not lost 82
350 pounds saved for the council in one
decision
ongoing costs saved thereafter every
year
this is fiscally and socially
responsible and i believe the only
humane response to the situation we find
ourselves in
politics does not have to be
oppositional
we are at our weakest when it becomes so
because it blinds us to potential and to
the good in others
please vote with that in mind and with
the strength of mind to stand with our
community at the time they need us the
most
what our political persuasion is does
not matter
what does matter is that here today and
now we do what we are supposed to do as
a chamber as a council and unite behind
our community
because that's what politics is that's
what it should do and that's what i
believe in
please unite us on this as i know that
you can
i move the amendment thank you very much
council why here do you have a secondary
you have a second er
councillor roth i have
counselor back jill bayford
um the one thing i'm an agreement with
councillor whitehead is is that this
cabinet cares passionately about
homeless people
uh people that need temporary
accommodation through circumstances that
any of us could find ourselves in
we have an excellent housing section and
excellent officers who have made
long-term provision
long-term sustainable provision
to
to find to find to locate and to fund
housing that
sorry
very tongue-tied um but it
it is not it is not opportunist it is it
is not one-off this this amount of money
is is minimal would go nowhere towards
preparing
providing the type of accommodation we
need i i think our long-term strategy is
much much more sustainable and i think
everyone should know that it will be far
better for the the people that need need
this
this accommodation long term
i i in that respect i i don't think in
any way that we should
support this amendment thank you
thank you for that clarification
counselor basically uh council ralph did
you wish to reserve the right when you
spoke
you did okay
council have counselor aura councillora
thank you
i i wholeheartedly support this
amendment uh chair and i hope the
my colleagues in this house tonight will
support as well some of us with my
colleagues from central harbor
and east cliff and part of cliftonville
market we
we are the councillor who who every day
we face homelessness and cases every day
we fight for them i have at the moment
three three cases
people actually living in a van
so we don't have an accommodation people
have been you know sleeping rough on our
doorstep people have been uh no clothes
no food in this weather sleeping rap
when we are the one of the sixth richest
country in the world
and i hope uh my colleagues will
understand this and support this thank
you
thank you very much councillora
councillor
keem thank you i just wanted to say that
yes it is a small amount compared to
what is needed to address the problem
but it is something and something now
rather than nothing at the moment and as
uh councillora has said we're all facing
this increase in homelessness cases and
the distress that causes people losing
jobs children losing education as they
have the disruption of moving schools
families split apart we need to do
something now thank you
thank you councillor keem
councillor wing
thank you i think first of all we need
to respect the the words spoken by
everybody in this room uh uh that we we
all have different opinions and i don't
think it's it's fair to this to describe
somebody's speech in a derogatory way
that's what i'd like to say first of all
so i respect what our colleagues on the
opposition say but i'm in central
harbour
where we have a crisis happening right
now i think in the main towns
particularly in margate and ramsgate
we're particularly hit by a a homeless
crisis particularly homeless people with
with pets we don't seem to have any sort
of structure where we can house people
with pets and if you're a lone woman in
a tent sleeping in the king george park
and you happen to have a pet that
happens to be a dog then that's a that's
a that's a real a comfort to you but
it's also your safety net as well i will
support this amendment i know the money
is a small amount what we've got to
remember is a third of people who live
in fanet of households in fanuc have a
an income of less than 20 000 and that's
the reality when we sat in our house i'm
lucky enough to own my home when we sat
in our houses a third of people that
live in thanet have a household income
of less than twenty thousand and when
you look at the the rent that's going
i've got a somebody's been evicted from
a house in central harbour her rent was
was five thirty
the landlord's painted it he's put some
insulation in and that house has been
back on the market at nine nine two five
we've got we've got a perfect storm for
homelessness and we need to do
everything we can to support our rise
team who are increasingly asked to work
miracles with with with
with increased numbers and not enough
accommodation locally thank you
thank you very much councillor wing
councillor austin
i think i largely wanted to say the same
as councillor wing um i noticed that in
a new recent newspaper article ramsgate
has been highlighted as one of the four
places in the country with the highest
rise in rents recently and i do think if
we're looking at the prospect of having
to pay 20 increases in rent then we
really do need to be looking in the long
term at our uh strategy for ensuring
that we can provide emergency
accommodation we do seem to have a
tendency to shy away from paying out now
in order to save later on a number of
issues and i do think that this is an
area where we really do need to consider
the human cost but also the financial
cost to this council in the longer term
if we don't take this opportunity now
thank you
thank you very much indeed councillor
austin sorry i just count of infamy
councillor ashby yes do thank you chair
um i'd actually like to agree with you
council austin
this administration
is concentrating on solving the problem
for the 2000 residents that we have
displaced here
as we have tried to explain
if we only put the small amount of 400
000 into it that will probably get lost
in even just the administration of
trying to find a solution for that
particular unit we know it won't provide
a unit
this
this um
administration is very very aware of the
situation i see it every day in my world
as well it's not just unique to ramsgate
or broad you know it's happening in
broad stairs it's happening in margate
but it's also happening in some of the
villages as well which never get a
mention in this council but that does
exist and we have we have people
sleeping in tents in westgate
and in and in birchington so it is not
unique to to your particular ward or or
it's not unique just to
um ramsgate and margate
it is our duty and the little time that
we've got left in our administration
which is i think now about 14 months we
will do everything we can to find a long
term
a longer sustainable future for our
social housing
and that that is our plan um i get the
point where
which you're trying to make but it is a
very a big focus of ours and it is
something that is very dear to my heart
if i could provide a solution next week
for all of our homeless people in sanet
then i would very much like to do that
but this particular amount of money is
not going to address the issue it will
probably just get dwindled away in in
the overall scheme of things we must
find a solution we must work with other
partners we must find some land which we
have got the land we need to free it up
we have this conversation very
frequently i alone have
spoken to the um
leader of kent county council asking to
give us the land or sell us the land
back
for the old deaf role school for the
deaf in margate so this administration
is very conscious of this and it is a
big focus of ours and it is a subject
that is there to my heart so although i
appreciate the the the um
if you like the plea
for the 400 000 this is a much much
bigger picture and i'm very aware of it
and it is something that we are working
very much towards so
i'd just like to agree with you on that
point thank you
thank you for that perspective leader uh
councillor everett did you want to come
in
i did chair thank you um
i think the issue of of homelessness is
is something which concerns all of us
and uh
you know as a war councillor in
newington the heart-rending stories i
get from people about the conditions in
which they live and which i know that
this council is not in a position to
address
is quite disturbing um but narrowly on
the issue of homelessness
this proposal makes financial sense and
i hear what um members obviously are
saying about it being not being enough
and of course it's not enough because
the problem is massive
nevertheless i don't see how we'd be
worse off by putting this sum of money
up against the problem
we do need to think bigger we probably
need to borrow money to build things to
do this stuff and the reality is this is
the financially prudent approach the
financially prudent approach is to
invest now it's not to put it in a
reserve which we may use to pay off debt
at some point in the future or we may
come up with something better to do with
that money
we need to address this this issue as it
is now councillor ashby mentioned kent
county council now i'm not an expert on
county council i've heard that they were
trying to cut their budget to support
homelessness that's what's come back to
me so i'm a bit disturbed really if
we're going to rely on them for any
assistance but i think the most
important thing for people to understand
is
reducing our reliance on out of area
accommodation and betting breakfast
will reduce costs to every resident of
family we will all be better off if we
make better provision for people who are
facing homelessness and i really urge
the council to support this financially
sensible
prudent amendment so financially prudent
that even margaret thatcher might have
supported council disorders
thank you for that councillor evans
counselor duckworth i did think you
might want to say something did you
no no you don't
cancel my head you can't come back and
you've already spoken uh councillor roth
um you reserved the right
thank you chair uh i just
wanna
say i welcome uh that we were trying to
have a
long-term solution but we have to act
now
what happened tomorrow where we get
somebody's homeless and standing on on a
street or
we we can't say oh wait until we build a
another house for you then we will put
you there
we need to support this amendment and we
need to stand behind those people this
is the people born and braided in this
country please
support this motion
thank you very much councillor wolf now
it's a risk of winding anybody up
councillor saunders
councillor yates yes you can just nip in
just briefly
thank you chair and apologies cancer
saunders um
i just want a clarification really i
think it was mentioned at cabinet that
this amount of money could actually fund
um
two or three units
um
so that's
that is
[Music]
so
so i i think
the point that we are making
and everyone in this chamber is making
is that
this isn't enough money we agree
but it is it is enough
to start the ball rolling thank you
counselor bayford yes didn't see you
there yeah just a small point i mean uh
agree with everybody you know it is a
major problem
and we're committed to doing something
about it um but i'm just not sure the
way labour go about these things because
now we're talking about 400 500 000 but
if you've got your first amendment
through there only been about 300 000 so
you seem to sort of double count and not
count which is exactly what you've
always done
all right all right
councillor saunders to wind up thank you
i think that's called forward planning
um
i'd just like to say that we did look at
the
the the subject very closely um i think
it was me some that's now being looked
at
now that we've
even
turned down the first amendment
looking at at it seriously that would
just about cover
the cost of the architectural
fee that would be required to
follow the model that we are uh looking
to pursue within our strategy
and it's absolutely true to say that our
strategy
does include
money
that we will probably end up borrowing
but we do have a model
i think everyone agrees that the
firehouse
model is very successful and it's the
way to go had we had a suitable property
to pursue
in that same model situation where we
were providing more than one unit for
our homeless people then we certainly
would have prepared and submitted a
different budget but the fact is we
haven't found a suitable unit the
housing team have been looking for
suitable units
they haven't found those units and you
have my assurance in the assurance of
the cabinet that should a suitable unit
come
become available we will make the funds
and we will find the funds necessary to
actually pursue that model thank you
thank you for that clarification council
saunders i shall now move to a vote on
the amendment
and i shall turn to the monitoring
officer
thank you chair so again you're voting
for or against the amendment or
abstaining council at albany
ashby against
councillor austin
councillor bambridge
councillor jill bayford
councillor robert bayford
councillor boyd
councillor braidwood
councillor coleman cook
councillor crittenden
councillor curry
four
councillor dennis
councillor dexter
councillor duckworth
councillor everett
council of fellows
councillor ghana
councillor gregory
four
councillor hart
councillor hopkinson
councillor huxley
councillor keane
councillor cup
councillor lays
uh councillor paul moore
councillor ovindon
councillor parsons
councillor linda piper
councillor stuart piper
councillor ratigan
councillor roth
councillor rogers
councillor rozeki
councillor david saunders
councillor maeve saunders
councillor savage against
councillor scobee
councillor scott
councillor shank
councillor schrub
councillor smith
councillor tomlinson
councillor towning
councillor whitehead
four
councillor wing
councillor wright
councillor yates
that's lost chair 29
against and 24.
thank you very much indeed i therefore
return to the main agenda item and i
need to instruct the deputy monitoring
officer to conduct a recorded vote for
the motion
yes for the agenda
i believe
we're back to the subject that's
we need to return to the debate before
going to the vote so does anybody else
wish to speak councillor everett
um yes can i thank the officers and
indeed the cabinet members for their
work on the um
on the budget
um these are difficult financial times i
seem to be saying that every time i
speak at a budget debate
going back over many years
but nonetheless it remains true
we respect the budget process i hope you
um understand that we have brought
forward our amendments in a proper way
through the process
we've been transparent about what we've
been doing we've discussed them with
officers we believe they were reasonable
we're disappointed you voted against
them and the labour group will support
the budget thank you
thank you indeed counselor everett now
again a day accounts have saunders would
you like to wind up
i think
everything that needed to be said has
been said and i thank um the opposition
for their support thank you very much
and i
do believe
they understand much of the effort and
work that's gone into producing this
balanced budget
disappointing that we can't agree on
every aspect of the budget
but i'm sure our good working
relationship will carry on in the new
financial year thank you chairman
thank you council saunders and i'm sure
that's all true i therefore returned to
the deputy monitor officer to conduct
the recorded vote
thank you chair
so we're now voting on the uh budget
paper itself
so four against or or abstain um
councillor alban
councillor ara four
councillor ashby
councillor austin
[Music]
councillor bambridge
councillor jill bayford
councillor robert bayford
councillor boyd
councillor
braidwood councillor coleman cook
councillor crittenden
councillor curry paul
councillor dennis
councillor dexter
councillor duckworth
councillor everett
councillor fellows
councillor ghana
councillor gregory four
councillor heart hart
councillor hopkinson
councillor huxley
councillor keane
councillor cup
councillor lays
councillor paul moore
councillor ovindon
councillor parsons
councillor linda piper
councillor stuart piper
councillor ratigan
councillor rorf
councillor rogers
councillor rogers
councillor roseki
councillor david saunders
councillor maeve saunders
councillor savage
councillor scobee
councillor scott
councillor shank
councillor schrub
councillor smith
councillor
tomlinson council of towning
councillor wallin
councillor whitehood whitehead four
councillor wing
councillor right
councillor yates
thank you very much that's me
anonymous
thank you very much indeed uh monitoring
officer that is carried obviously i
thank you very much uh just before we
conclude business uh i'm informed mr
blundell would like to make a point of
clarification about the hra report
thank you chair i just wanted to correct
a statement i made earlier in response
to
councillor everett and my apologies to
cancer ever in the chamber it was indeed
the affordable rents that were frozen
and not the social rents as i mistakenly
made
my apologies
thank you mr blundell